[Aplausos]
[Música]
muchos nos habéis pedido que hagamos un
vídeo hablando sobre rumania y es que
por sorprendente que parezca hay muchos
rumanos que siguen este canal y porque
os preguntaréis lo cierto es que rumanía
es el país de origen de la mayor parte
de inmigrantes que hay en españa muy por
encima de otros lugares donde el español
es la lengua oficial tal cual como lo
oís españa es el hogar de más de 750 mil
inmigrantes rumanos y además como el
rumano es un idioma muy parecido al
español enseguida lo aprenden y terminan
hablando un castellano perfecto como si
fueran del mismísimo valladolid
pero no sólo eso además teníamos que
hablar de rumanía un país que puede
convertirse en la primera democracia del
mundo en legalizar la corrupción habéis
oído bien en enero de 2017 el parlamento
rumano aprobó un decreto en el que se
despenalizaba el cobro de sobornos por
un valor inferior a 44 mil euros tal
cual sin necesidad de ir a la cárcel ni
pagar ninguna multa ni siquiera pasar
por un juzgado como os podéis imaginar
la aprobación de este decreto ha
desatado toda clase de protestas en
rumanía
muchos rumanos ya estaban hartos de ser
el país más corrupto de la unión europea
y este decreto ha sido la gota que ha
colmado el vaso pero la pregunta es cómo
han llegado hasta aquí qué puede pasar
en un país para que su gobierno se
atreva a sacar semejantes leyes con
tantísimo descaro hoy vamos a responder
a esta pregunta pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
[Música]
la corea del norte europea no se puede
conocer la historia de rumanía sin
hablar de nicolae ceausescu el kim
jong-un europeo
[Música]
como hungría o bulgaria también
padecieron dictaduras comunistas pero el
caso de rumanía es especial desde que
nicolae ceausescu llegara a ser
presidente en 1974
rumanía se aisló del resto del mundo
incluida la propia unión soviética
pronto los alimentos empezaron a
escasear pero mientras a los ciudadanos
se les relacionaba la comida ceausescu
se gastaba el dinero público en
construir palacios faraónicos para que
os hagáis una idea el parlamento de
bucarest construido en 1983 es el
parlamento más grande del mundo esto es
sorprendente si tenemos en cuenta que la
población de rumanía apenas llega a los
22 millones de habitantes
pero es que además se estima que para
las obras hubo que emplear a más de
20.000 trabajadores de los cuales 3.000
murieron por extenuación pero no sólo
eso además ceausescu obligaba a sus
propios ciudadanos para que participaran
en desfiles y espectáculos de masas
dedicados a glorificar la imagen del
dictador claro que había que cantar no
había elección siempre había alguien el
partido en medio
cómo se llamaba livy activistas y
activistas había uno por cada cinco o
seis personas con las consignas que
había que cantar o gritar si decías
cualquier otra cosa te restaban a ti
mismo y al igual que sus compañeros
norcoreanos nicolae ceausescu era un
auténtico maestro en el arte de la
represión política se estima que en los
años ochenta uno de cada 30 rumanos
pertenecía a la policía política podía
ser tu vecino o tu peluquero y si en
algún momento bien fuera en tu trabajo
cafetería del barrio se te ocurría decir
algo en contra del régimen podías
terminar en la cárcel o simplemente
desaparecer sin embargo y pese a todo
esto la profesión de dictador es un
oficio más arriesgado de lo que parece
y estas imágenes que veis pertenecen al
último discurso de ceausescu el 21 de
diciembre de 1989 fijaros en la
expresión de su cara y como la cámara
empieza a temblar
justo ese es el momento en el que el
público empezó a abuchearlo
así es como comenzaron las mayores
protestas hasta la fecha en la historia
de rumanía miles de ciudadanos se
lanzaron a las calles con banderas
rumanas a las que les habían recortado
los símbolos comunistas y tres días
después concretamente el día de navidad
de ese mismo año nicolae ceausescu moría
junto a su mujer a manos de sus propios
compañeros de partido sus últimas
palabras fueron la historia me vengará
[Música]
y os preguntaréis qué pasó después lo
cierto es que en rumanía fruto de esa
represión política no existía ninguna
oposición al régimen por hacer una
comparativa en otros países como polonia
ya existía un sindicato como solidaridad
dirigido por les walesa con suficiente
apoyo popular y suficiente organización
como para tomar el gobierno y dirigir al
país hacia una transición democrática
sin embargo quién creéis que sucedió a
ceausescu en rumanía pues efectivamente
sus propios compañeros de partido más
concretamente este señor que veis aquí
que se llamaba guión y belleza
[Música]
os podéis imaginar este nuevo gobierno
no estaba dispuesto a perder todos esos
privilegios y ese estilo de vida que
habían disfrutado durante la época de
ceausescu así que como siempre suele
pasar en estos casos el régimen político
en rumanía cambió pero salud
[Música]
por supuesto que la nueva constitución
rumana aceptaba que otros partidos
políticos se presentarán a las
elecciones incluso el antiguo partido
comunista cambia de nombre y pasó a
llamarse el partido socialdemócrata pero
los mismos altos cargos que tenían el
poder en época de ceausescu lo
mantuvieron durante la década de los 90
y los 2000 y como ya sabéis si el poder
corrompe y el poder absoluto corrompe
absolutamente para que os hagáis una
idea en 1995 el 50 por ciento de la
economía polaca ya estaba en manos
privadas en el caso de rumanía solamente
el 35 por ciento
[Música]
si queréis un ejemplo vamos a tomar dos
fábricas de coches en chequia tenían una
empresa estatal que se llamaba la ex
coda y que fue privatizada en el año
1992 repartiendo los títulos de
propiedad entre los propios trabajadores
su equivalente en rumanía gracia no fue
privatizada hasta 1997 y en vez de
repartir los títulos directamente el
gobierno se la vendió al grupo renault
e
en otras palabras durante los años 90 y
2000 las élites comunistas romanas
hicieron todo lo que pudieron para
mantener el control económico y político
del país sólo así podrían evitar que
nadie pudiera fiscalizar lo que hacían y
mantener sus corruptelas pero esperad un
momento porque la corrupción también
estaba pequeño nivel en un país tan
acostumbrado a la escasez era imposible
conseguir nada sin hacer algún pequeño
soborno quieres que te atienda al médico
regalarle un cartón de tabaco quieres
tener electricidad en casa una botella
de whisky unos cuantos billetes y asunto
arreglado
así es como un país entero hizo de la
corrupción un sistema de vida y os
preguntaréis puede funcionar un país así
lo cierto es que no los rumanos veían
como otras repúblicas ex comunistas como
bolonia o chequia empezaban a tener unos
estándares de vida más parecidos a los
de europa occidental mientras ellos
continuaban mal viviendo con menos de
400 dólares al mes y por eso a mediados
de los años 2000
rumanía solicita la entrada en la unión
europea para poder disfrutar de esos
fondos de cohesión que da bruselas y
bruselas dice vale os dejamos entrar
pero con una condición y esa condición
fue
el directorio nacional anticorrupción en
el año 2002 el gobierno rumano funda una
agencia anticorrupción el llamado
directorio nacional anticorrupción o
como se le conoce habitualmente el de n
a durante los primeros años esta agencia
estaba controlado por fiscales afines a
este partido socialdemócrata así que era
una forma de decir mira bruselas bs
estoy limpiando mi país contra la
corrupción la alan alda la estoy
limpiando el país pero de nuevo no
cambiaba absolutamente nada
[Música]
sin embargo en el año 2013 ocurrió algo
que nadie se esperaba fue el momento en
el que entró en escena una mujer
dispuesta a enfrentarse a todo y a todos
-laura con ruta coves
[Música]
los rumanos parecen impresionados con
las actividades del dna según una
encuesta el 60% de la población dice que
confía en la agencia mientras que sólo
el 11% confía en el parlamento en sólo
dos años pobres y ha metido en la cárcel
a más de 1100 políticos acusados por
casos de corrupción durante estos años
los rumanos han descubierto todos los
tejemanejes que se trae a su clase
política y no son pocos según
estimaciones la corrupción en rumanía
supone nada menos que el 15 por ciento
de su producto interior bruto
prácticamente todos los contratos
públicos tienen algún tipo de soborno o
de sobrecostes
incluso las licencias de windows y the
office que utilizan los funcionarios del
gobierno romano llevan un sobrecoste de
hasta tres millones de euros que se han
ido en pagar sobornos al funcionario y
al oficial del gobierno de turno una
jueza por ejemplo llegó a cobrar más de
630 mil euros por declara de inocencia
un criminal desde el año 2013 todos esos
delincuentes están llenando las cárceles
del país hasta tal punto que muchas
prisiones ya no tienen espacio para más
presos pero no sólo eso lo más
importante es que la propia sociedad
rumana se ha dado cuenta de lo
importante y lo con sueños a que puede
ser la corrupción y de hecho las cosas
empezaron a tomar otro cariz con esta
noticia
un incendio en un club de bucarest deja
27 muertos y varios heridos este caso
desató toda una oleada de protestas en
toda rumanía al parecer este incendio se
podría haber evitado si el local hubiera
cumplido con las normativas anti
incendios correspondientes pero resulta
que el dueño del club había sobornado a
la autoridad política de turno para que
le permitieran abrir su negocio sin
cumplir con las regulaciones y así es
como nació la plataforma corrüptia buzzi
de la corrupción mata
a través de las redes sociales los
rumanos su sociedad civil empezó a
organizarse en grupos de protesta y de
monitorización contra la corrupción pero
esperad un momento porque todavía queda
lo mejor
[Música]
la mayor protesta de la historia de
rumanía el 18 de enero del año 2017 a
las 10 de la noche el gobierno
socialdemócrata con su primer ministro
son ingrid del agua la cabeza aprueba un
decreto de urgencia y si lo hace a las
10 de la noche cuando todo el mundo
estaba a punto de meterse en la cámara y
que decía este decreto pues que todos
los políticos que hubieran aceptado
sobornos por valor inferior a 44 mil
euros no tenían que ir a la cárcel ni
siquiera a pagar ninguna multa ni ningún
tipo de indemnización vamos como si no
hubieran hecho nada más
para más inri este decreto se presentó
en el momento en el cual el parlamento
estaba teniendo su debate sobre los
presupuestos así como de tapadillo para
que nadie se llegara a enterar y os
preguntaréis a quién se le ocurre sacar
semejante decreto con este descaro es
decir cuál fue el argumento oficial del
gobierno para descriminalizar la
corrupción pues bien esta fue la razón
que dio el primer ministro
sorín green de nagua
[Aplausos]
y quiere aprobar este decreto para
evitar la superpoblación en las
prisiones
[Música]
esta es la razón oficial que ha dado el
gobierno de rumanía tal cual como lo oís
es más según estimaciones de la
autoridad de presiones rumana con este
decreto se liberarían a más de 3000
políticos corruptos y ojo es verdad que
en muchas cárceles rumanas tienen
superpoblación eso es un hecho pero
vamos a ver un país que se puede
permitir el lujo de pagar sobre costos
por prácticamente todo
también puede construir más cárceles no
os parece
[Aplausos]
además el hecho de que prácticamente
todos esos políticos que están entre
rejas pertenecen al mismo partido que
además es el partido del gobierno es un
poquito sospechoso no os parece lo mismo
pensaron los más de 500.000 rumanos que
se lanzaron a las calles de bucarest
minutos después de que se aprobara este
decreto
[Música]
a través de la plataforma la corrupción
mata los ciudadanos se enteraron
enseguida de la noticia y no les hizo
mucha gracia así es cómo surgió la mayor
protesta de la historia de rumanía
[Música]
nunca pensé que esto sería posible
siempre pensaba que había una lógica un
sentido común detrás de cada ley pero
ahora que ha pasado esto veo que me
equivocaba las protestas se alargaron
durante días no sólo en bucarest sino
también en todas las demás ciudades de
rumanía y la primera víctima de este
malestar fue el ministro de justicia que
tuvo que dimitir el 9 de febrero de 2017
el gobierno además ha tenido que retirar
este decreto aunque ya han dicho que
solo lo van a hacer de forma temporal y
el nuevo ministro tutor el trader ha
llegado al gobierno con una misión bien
clara justificar el despido del fiscal
general del estado y de la fiscal jefe
del dna nuestro amiga laura contrata
coves
[Música]
la mujer
de mil políticos por supuesto que desde
el gobierno acusan a esta mujer y haber
emprendido toda una caza de brujas pero
lo cierto es que con la ley en la mano
no han sido capaces de encontrar ningún
argumento que justifique su destino
tras evaluar todos los factores
constitucionales legales y de
oportunidad he decidido que por el
momento no es aconsejable empezar los
mecanismos institucionales para revocar
al fiscal federal ya la fiscal jefe del
dna mientras tanto el gobierno de solín
green de now está acorralado por dos
lados por uno tiene a la sociedad civil
rumana vigilando todos los movimientos
que hace y por el otro tiene a las
autoridades europeas presionándole para
que deje de entorpecer el trabajo de los
fiscales anticorrupción
[Música]
y por supuesto estas élites políticas
que no olvidéis que son herederas del
régimen de ceausescu recurren a teorías
conspiranoicas para defenderse según
ellos todas estas protestas están
orquestadas por georges soros y nos
rafael en su opinión la corrupción no
debe de ser un problema tan grave en
rumanía pero con o sin conspiraciones
esta es toda una crisis existencial en
el tercer país más pobre de la unión
europea
así que la pregunta es creéis que
rumanía debería encarcelar a todos esos
políticos corruptos para poder llegar
algún día a estar a la altura de sus
vecinos europeos o pensáis que
efectivamente el gobierno de sorín
grinder out hace bien en despenalizar
los sobornos podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y si
queréis conocer otro caso de revolución
ciudadana en este otro libro contó os
explica lo que es la revolución de los
paraguas si queréis verlo hacer click
aquí
y por supuesto no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribirse al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]